[Music]
since the release of the first season of
a Netflix series though which
everybody's talking about it but what
about a second season it's clear that
there will definitely be one and that
the characters in season two will be
brought closer together one character
that hasn't been seen so far but which
they just can't get around is Jared's
mentor namely vesemir more than a year
ago the question arose who should embody
the old still living witcher the
undisputed number one on the fans wish
list is definitely star wars veteran
Mark Hamill who jokingly said in a tweet
in 2018 that he has no idea who Bethany
is but that the role should be played by
him The Witcher showrunner Lauren his
resent said that this news almost caught
her a heart attack in a positive way
however what are the chances that Hamill
will actually play vesemir probably not
that good because the shooting starts
already in spring and so far nobody
seems to have officially approached
Tambor but who knows what's happening
behind the scenes at the moment
nevertheless fans of the actor shouldn't
give up hope because The Witcher series
is designed for many seasons and the
probability is quite high that vesemir
will show up sooner or later
with or without Mark Hamill there's been
speculation about the future of Deadpool
at Disney for a long time some people
thought their Deadpool would no longer
be r-rated but child-friendly
others even feared that after the second
part the series would end main actor
Ryan Reynolds finally brings the light
into the dark when he was a guest on
life with Kelly and Ryan he revealed
that he's currently working on Deadpool
3 for the whole team and at the same
time he raved about his new place of
work the Marvel Studios however he was
silent about a release date what's also
unclear is who might be a possible
Director for Deadpool free especially
the age rating should be very important
for many fans as a Deadpool movie
without our rating would be a
catastrophe for many we can only hope
that we will soon find out more and that
the shooting will start this year the
turn of the year is traditionally always
a good occasion for a look back Netflix
thought the same thing and published a
list of the most popular movies and
series we're supposed to have watched
most often do
in the past year please note that the
lists differ from country to country in
the United States for example the
serious murder mystery is in first place
the silver medal goes to the action
blockbuster six underground also on the
top ten among others included are triple
frontier The Incredibles 2 and the Mafia
epic the Irishman but the statistics
seem to be pretty far-fetched the only
basis of assessment is whether the
viewer has watched the first two minutes
of the film or serious in the first 28
days so sometimes it doesn't matter if
the movies or series are captivating
since some of the films and series are
not even 28 days old the statistics so
far are probably extrapolated Netflix
seems to be pushing its own original
productions up the rankings also not
included in the statistics are so-called
sleepers which are movies or series that
take a certain amount of time to reach
the audience only then generate views
and are therefore not directly
successful the bottom line is that the
published top 10 lists of Netflix are
not representative for a top 10 list
that is based on facts so we believe
that the total generated watch time is
an absolute must which has unfortunately
been completely left out of the equation
if you take a look at the reporting of
online platforms for film news it is
also noticeable that hardly anyone seems
to question these statistics what a pity
because these statistics are
unfortunately nothing but I wash in any
case what we really want to know is what
your real favorites from 2019 are so
feel free to add them to the comments
section below
this year the Marvel series 1 division
will celebrate its premiere on Disney
Plus and this despite the fact that it
was actually announced at the San Diego
comic-con that the series would not be
released until 2021 via Twitter Disney's
now announced that one division has been
brought forward
this makes the series one of the Marvel
highlights this year along with movies
like Black Widow the turtles and the
Sirius the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
not much is known about the content yet
but it is clear that elizabeth Olsen
will portray the role as scarlet which
occur when the Maximoff and Paul
as efficient also in the cast are kat
dennings as Darcy Lewis and Yana Paris
as Monica Rambeau when exactly one
division will be released is also not
yet clear however we expect new
information about the release soon all
over the world The Adventures of Aang
and his friends are known and loved of
course we're talking about the anime
series avatar last year Netflix
announced that they wanted to release a
specially produced series about it not
in a comic but in a live-action format
after a long time without any news about
the current development comic book
published an article a few days ago
about a podcast with dubbing actress
Jessie flower who depth in the English
original Ansgar friend tuff shortly
before the end of the reckoning she
revealed that the filming will start in
early 2020 this surprised many fans
because there's no information about the
cast of the series yet what is clear is
that Netflix will work closely with the
people who were already involved in the
production of the original series it
remains to be seen who will eventually
take on the roles of the live-action
remake the release date is unfortunately
in not yet known just a few weeks ago we
reported that the Uncharted filming will
Tom Holland in the leading role is
finally about to start shooting after
the directors favorite O'Russell Seth
Gordon Shawn Levy and Ben Trachtenberg
left the project in the past most
recently bond will be directed Travis
Knight once the director of Uncharted
but as deadline now reports he also
create the project for scheduling
reasons it is therefore clear that the
planned cinema release on December 17
2020 can by no means be realized even if
a new director could be found quickly
Tom Hollands already in the middle of
shooting spider-man this summer it's
also unclear to what extent the script
is finished
so the search goes on for now and of
course it's not completely unlikely that
the project will be cancelled after all
[Music]